[Music]
jeremy is in ohio
hi jeremy welcome to the dave ramsey
show
yeah hello dave uh i just got a question
for you or a little bit or maybe
you can uh think about my situation here
i'm a laid off coal miner of uh 15 years
and uh i'm wanting to start a business
and i'm going to do a
rollover for job or for a business
startup have you ever heard of the robs
yes account with my 401k yeah
and i know it sounds like somebody's
trying to sell you a franchise
yeah well it's not a franchise it's just
starting to start the business
and they're trying to sell you a
business in a box though i mean
no no no no this is a business i want to
start a
uh a service center in my local hometown
uh which is a college town
and it should get enough business to uh
sustain itself
okay and uh like an auto service center
yes sir uh i like uh tires and brakes
and little changes and uh
is there a is there a brand name company
that's trying to sell you a dealership
that's pitching you the rob
no really you just dug us up off the
internet
yes okay because 99 of the time i get
this question it's some franchise
salesman trying to show you how to
finance the deal that they want to sell
you and that's what i was trying to
figure out
okay so you're starting a scrap you're
starting something from scratch you're
going to put your name on the front of
it
and uh you're starting uh cold cold
turkey so how much is in your 401k
uh 174 000. what's it going to take to
start this place
uh the building is 120 000. why do you
need to buy the building won't you rent
it
um i i got the building that i talked
the guy down from 155 to 120 so i figure
if it doesn't work out i could sell the
business and make money on the 401k
well you would sell the yeah you know
you need to keep the business and the
real estate separate
in your at least in your mind okay yes
you can you could buy the building um
by rolling the 401k into a self-directed
ira and put the real estate in that and
then buy them
and then build the business using the
other technique
yeah but you're not having money
uh well i throughout the years i've i've
saved about
uh about thirteen thousand dollars to
live off of
and uh i don't have any debt uh my home
is paid for my cars are paid for i have
no credit card i have no student loans
so the other thing i have is
cell phone electric water how long do
you think it's going to take you to get
this business up and going
i'm hoping about a year okay why don't
we rent this building from this guy for
two years with an option to purchase
it okay he will do that but
get a different building because you you
are going all in
you're doing james bond on me you're
pushing all the chips to the middle of
the table on one hand
and this is either going to work or it's
not and you're going to be broke or
you're going to
feel like you hit the home run and i i
don't push my chips all them to the
middle of the table anymore my life's
too short i don't do that
and so i want you to break this up in
some way where you're not using up every
dime you have on an idea that is
completely unproven
except between accepting your dreams
over coffee in the morning
and he mentioned this is a college town
so there will be enough traffic
and i'm watching my old college
colleagues talking about not coming back
or doing the whole fall online so it
just takes one weird
glitch in the matrix when you're all in
even when it's a sure thing the college
gets discovered there's not a shirt
there's no such thing as a sure thing
the rules in business are it takes twice
as long as you think it's going to cost
twice
as much as you think it's going to and
you're not the exception those are the
three rules
and i have to remind myself and my team
of them all the time because we always
get all hyped up and we can see all we
see you know every entrepreneur is an
optimist we have six ideas in the shower
every morning and we just know that we
know that we know that this is all gonna
work out
and most of our ideas suck and i don't
think this is a bad
idea but i don't think you don't i'm
positive
you don't know what you don't know about
what's gonna happen here and how long is
it going to take and how hard it's going
to be
please don't use up your last dime and
most of it really not on the business
most of it on the piece of real estate
so when you walk away from the shop
and you come back a month later there's
a real good chance he's going to rent it
to you
with an option to purchase over the next
three years
you get the business up and running and
then you want to roll some of that money
into a self-directed ira and buy that pr
shop i won't gripe about it too much
but um but i i just i you call me
i love your dream i want you to run a
business i want you to open the shop
i do not want you to put all your chips
in the middle of the table on one hand
that's scaring the crap out of me for
you and i wouldn't do that and i
wouldn't recommend my best friend do
that and uh for this moment you're my
best friend don't do that
so hold on i'm gonna send you a copy of
the book entre leadership which is our
playbook around here how we grew our
business
from a card table in my living room over
to the
uh over to where it is today and so it's
our playbook hold on kelly will pick up
and
get